Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmetische angelegenheiten mein name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur ausgabe achtundsiebzig
unserer gesprächs reihe über all die tollen themen die unser wild all so anbietet und,
heute gehts nach längerer zeit mal wir um himmelskörper in unserem sonnensystem da man ja schon so einige betrachtet,
den merkur die venus äh hatten wir schon im blick und sehr ausführlich haben wir uns auch das saturn system angeschaut
und ja jetzt gibt es noch so 'n anderes objekt was jüngst näherer untersuchung unterzogen wurde und ich dachte mir jetzt ist es doch mal an der zeit mal zu schauen was dabei herausgekommen ist konkret geht es um,
den pluto den zwerg planeten ganz weit draußen in unserem sonnensystem um darüber alles zu erfahren was dort passiert ist und was für erkenntnisse gewonnen werden konnten bis heute,
spreche ich heute mit martin petzold schönen guten tag,
wir sind nämlich jetzt in köln in der universität köln genauer ist das hier sich das richtig dem rheinischen institut für umwelt forschung unterordnen.
Das ist eine abteilung abteilung planeten forschung im rheinischen institut für umwelt forschung an der universität zu köln,
und in dem langen namen das wichtigste wort ist an,
ist ein sogenanntes an institut es gehört nicht der universität ist aber mit der universität assoziiert wir haben da also,
so eine art kooperation mit der universität,
wir sind ein eingetragener verein zur förderung der wissenschaften und dürfen die infrastruktur der universität,
benutzen anerkannt von der universität und wir führen also deswegen auch den haben an der universität zu köln im namen und auch unsere e-mail adresse zum beispiel lauten alle uni köln de.
Das heißt hier gibt's also ein eine abteilung der planeten forschung deren leiter oder cola.
Ja ich bin der direktor dieses diese abteilung.
Ein bisschen ungewöhnlich oder umwelt forschung planeten forsche.
Ja das ist ein bisschen historisch zu sehen ist eine ausgründung also das ranch institut für umwelt forschung ist eine ausgründung aus einem universität institut es ging,
dabei damals vor fünfundzwanzig jahren glaube ich mindestens,
um die erdatmosphäre verschmutzung der erdatmosphäre und ausbreitung der verschmutzung voraus rechnung sogenannte eurer projekt und das ging das sind von der eu zum teil gefördert worden
und das ging über jahrzehnte und so was können sie dann im rahmen eines wenn sie mit dem mitarbeiter halten wollen im rahmen,
eines universität instituts nicht mehr betreiben wurde das aus gegründet wesentlichen aus formal arbeitsrechtliche,
und.
Ich war bis zweitausendsieben mit meiner gruppe radio sondierung radio im institut für physik und
mythologie zunächst als seit neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig als wissenschaftlicher assistent dann hochschule dozent dann vertreten der professor
und zweitausendsieben haben wir uns dann,
diesem institut angeschlossen haben diese abteilung gegründet ich hatte so viele,
lange häufige projekte und so viel geld dafür auch,
das also irgendwie die universität da keine möglichkeit zu haben und,
wir waren war so beteiligt an setter,
hatte.
Der.
Sechs experiment ja experiment auf rosita und das ging dann über zweiundzwanzig jahre und,
das ist das experiment gewesen also radio seins investigation,
äh wir haben die schwere feld von einem kometen kern bestimmt und oberflächen strukturen arbeiten,
mit radio wählen und.
Schwere feld kann man mit radio wählen.
Ja das ist auch das experiment auf nur reisende einteile zumindest davon man schaut,
darauf dass also die anziehungskraft eines körpers die flugbahn eine raumsonde stören,
dabei die geschwindigkeit stören,
verändern und wenn man ein radio signal sendet dann verschiebt sich dann,
mit durch den doppelter effekt die sender frequenz und die kann man sehr präzise messen,
zumindest die verschiebung und kann dann aus diesen änderungen in der sende frequenz auf die masse schließen also auf die kraft und dann auf die masse.
Okay also das institut hat sich quasi aus der umwelt forschung heraus in interplast entwickelt.
Kann man so sagen ja also machen auch,
wir sind ja beteiligt an nicht nur an resetten sondern auch mal sex press venus express von den japanern
now reisenden und wir arbeiten an neuen discovery projekt mit der nasa haben wir jetzt popo soll's ab gesund wir haben noch,
lucy bin ich beteiligt von der nasa und da gibt's also,
vorschläge in den neuen discover runde für eine minus mission sondern,
atmosphäre also wir machen atmosphären forschung hier an mars und venus,
wir sind auch beteiligt an der isar mission julius und der sondierung,
in zehn zwanzig jahren der jupiter atmosphäre atmosphäre und forschung wir haben schwere feld forschung ähm machen oberflächen rauher.
Es ist sozusagen von der betrachtung der erde und das sind ja alles anwendung die man ja genauso auf die erde legen konnte hat sich dann sozusagen diese solar system expansion hier.
Ja also die die mitarbeiter als auch ich ich habe zwar astronomie studiert theologie kam dann hier nach köln,
geradezu ins kalte wasser geworfen noch nebenbei chio für sich dann lernen müssen ja ich bin,
privat dozent für physik und.
Aus dem geo physikalischen raus und die meisten mitarbeiter hier sind auch geox musiker wir haben glaube ich nur zwei physiker und äh,
betrachten dann eben plane theologie aus dem aus dem aus der sichtweise der physik planeten sind nicht so unterschiedlich.
Zumindest die drastischen,
die erde und das ganze geht dann weiter in die extra solarien planeten wir sind auch teile ich gewesen an,
im ersten desktop das nach extra solange planeten in explizit gesucht hat,
wann wir schwer beteiligt und machen weiter jetzt mit kappler und test und suchen nach extra solarium planeten finden sie im hunderter park wenn sie so wollen äh,
vielleicht darf ich da die geschichte erzählen,
des ist äh die das neue weltraum teleskop der nasa des vor kurzem gestartet wurde und ebenfalls noch extra sondern planeten sucht praktisch der kettler nachfolgerin so wollen,
und ich kann ihnen vielleicht eine geschichte erzählen ich hab neunzehnhundertneunundsiebzig angefangen astronomie zu studieren und mein professor war richtig alter,
gestandener astronom und,
das erste wasser und sagte das sonnensystem ist einmalig,
das kann's nicht nochmal geben da muss ein rädchen so ins andere greifen,
das geht nicht das ist einmalig heute würden wir sagen.
Ein sonnenlicht stern ohne planeten wäre was außergewöhnlich.
Wir sehen wenn wir es auflösen können bei jedem sohn ähnlichen stern planet es ist fantastisch.
Ist das geht dann direkt in die frage über nach äh leben im universum.
Und ich würde sagen das ganze universum muss voller leben quellen wir können's nicht entdecken aber es muss praktisch schweren quellen von erleben.
Ja die zahlen sprechen dafür einfach mit wahrscheinlichkeiten rangehen grade in den letzten zehn zwanzig jahren hat man immer wieder nur festgestellt wie wie durchschnittlich wäre ja eigentlich sind und dass diese ganze angenommene besonderheit eigentlich so ein bisschen,
annahme war die nicht richtig zutrifft wenn man das dann einfach mal hochrechnet auf die große anzahl von,
sterne erleiden allein nur in unserer galaxie von der es nochmal genauso viele gibt wie sterne tja da muss auch mal was zu finden sein,
es vielleicht nicht an uns das dann auch zu entdecken,
es gibt aber noch genug zu entdecken bei uns im sonnensystem wir wollen ja heute ein bisschen auf dem pluto zu sprechen kommen,
oder pluto ist irgendwie schon immer so 'ne besondere marke
gewesen vielleicht kann man mal so ein bisschen kurz in die vergangenheit reinschauen wie sich das so entwickelt hat ich glaube die offizielle entdeckung war so februar,
neunzehnhundert dreißig hat ihn hätte ihn glaube ich auch schon früher entdecken können auf irgendwelchen foto platten war zu sehen aber das muss man ja auch erstmal herausfinden aber,
dann war klar es gibt da etwas und,
auf einmal war schon wieder muss man sagen das sonnensystem noch etwas größer als man es eben noch wenige hundert jahre vorher angenommen hat.
Das war ja schon so die entdeckung von neptun uranus davor halt auch schon so,
besonderheit weil die halt einfach so dunkel sind dass man sie einfach,
nicht so einfach mal eben entdecken kann während saturn und jupiter sicher mehr oder weniger aufgedrängt haben am laufenden meter stellt man halt irgendwann fest oh voilà,
es geht ja immer weiter und es geht ja immer weiter und wenn man vielleicht auch am ende nochmal zu kommen diese ja diese vorstellung dass es vielleicht sogar noch weiter geht die rot ja auch nun überhaupt nicht,
wie es dazu gekommen und was was hat das damals so ausgelöst in der gastronomie.
Also nach pluto sondern oder nach einem objekt nach einem trans neptun wurde eigentlich lange gesucht,
genauso spekuliert wie es eigentlich nach,
uranus spekuliert wurde denn man hat ja woran us,
zufall mehr oder minder gefunden und dann hat man gesehen er hat die bahn störungen also die voraus berechnete
position am himmel stimmte nicht mit der tatsächlichen überein da gab's die idee eben tiefe des kapital zu uns gesetz ist dann muss es stört kräfte geben die die bewegung des uranus,
stören und man hat dann durch,
rechnung die position als objektes des stirb jückt des,
bestimmt und dort hat man auch in der nähe dieser position hat man dann den neptun denn aus späteren neptun gefunden und,
trotzdem gab es sowohl bei uranus als auch bei neptun weiter bahn störung zu sehen,
und was einmal klappt glaubt auch zweimal nur liest man da irgendwie ins leere hinein und.
Also es gab störungen man dachte so okay alles klar da muss noch noch der nächste planet zahlen aber man hat ihn nicht gefunden.
Noch einer man hat ihn so nicht gefunden aber es gab dann insbesondere in flex chef dann organisierte suchen da wurden in arizona zum beispiel an der sternwarte,
ähm da wurde ein junger mann angestellt kleid und der sollte einfach so da was gefunden.
Ja und das ging damals so dass man also den himmel fotografiert hat,
und dann gab es ein instrument das land der sich blink komm parador äh da hat man einfach zwei foto platten genommen,
sie in ein gerät eingelegt und konnte dann diese,
beiden foto platten gleichzeitig betrachten damit kann man so,
vielleicht kennen einige,
dass er sowas auch als spielzeug gibt was haben wir früher als kinder zu weihnachten bekommen es war so ein gerät wo sie so scheiben,
einlegen konnten und dann mit fotos und dann haben sie sowohl auf den linken als um rechten auge das selbe bild gehabt und bekam und stereo und äh bei den blick kompensator ist das praktisch genau dasselbe gewesen und,
aber wenn man jetzt die linke und die rechte scheibe nacheinander beleuchtet hatte,
dann waren alle objekte die,
auf den beiden platten unterschiedliche positionen hatten die sprang dann hin und her,
also alles was fix war das sah man weiterhin und das was eine position auf der platte änderte das sprang hin und her und so hatte man das war praktisch,
die die methode mit der man dann den pluto gefunden hat oder verifizieren dann und da war.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen so sucht man heute ausreden.
Na heute macht man es ein bisschen anders aber das ist ja.
Also nicht mehr zu platten aber halt so digital das.
Digital dass es nun ist nur noch digital und es geht dann anders.
Aber im vergleich sozusagen zeit aufnahme und schaut was sich bewegt.
Ja genau genau man untersucht dann die verschiedenen positionen und auf auf diesen digitalen.
Und äh da der diese dieses objekt was da gefunden wurde war dann für alles verantwortlich.
Bahn störungen von uranus unverblümt.
Dachte man.
Und da kam dann so eine masse heraus von fünf erdmann und.
Wann war das annahmen oder hatte man sozusagen gut.
Das waren das waren dann einfach heraus was brauche ich um diese bahnsteige für euren hund fünf,
maaßen heißt ja auch doppelt so groß wie erde und dann hat man so,
als in der schule war meine quartal wir hatten erdkunde und kollege hatte aufgabe oder ein ein vortrag zu halten über das sonnensystem und er sagte dann.
Merkur ist der kleinste planet im sonnensystem,
und ich hatte damals ich war glaub ich dreizehn vierzehn den neuen ddv atlas astronomie von joachim herrmann ja und da statt pluto ist der kleinste
und ich sag das stimmt nicht und er sagt dann steht hier im schulbuch ne na ich sag hier ich habe ihn noch,
je länger man also dann seine aufnahmen macht er seine seine beobachtung machte desto kleiner wurde pluto ja und das ging also so rasant dass also die schulbücher nicht hinterher kam.
Wie kann man denn sozusagen aus einer einfachen beobachtung diese masse und die größe herausziehen.
Zunächst einmal dass man zum beispiel sternberg deckung hatte und damit also zum beispiel eine gewisse größe dann aufgrund des.
Also ist der pluto an einem fix stern vor.
Genau also vor einem fixen vorbeizieht und dann solche größen dann bestimmen konnte,
und der tote stoß kam dann in den siebzigern also mit entdeckung von caron und dann.
Also dem mond.
Dem mond den mond des pluto den großen mond im außergewöhnlich großen blutmond von pluto und das war schon eine überraschung also der caron ist halb so groß wie blutung,
also ein größten und ein massenvergewaltigung was es im sonnensystem so nicht wieder gibt,
ja das nächste was ist haben sie dann mond und erde und dann kommt erstmal lange zeit gar nichts ähm,
und dann können sie mit kappler drei was im dritten gesetz wenn sie.
Die umlauf periode bestimmen und den abstand bestimmen können sie zumindest die system masse bestimmen und am,
klar ist noch kleiner als merkur also von der masse hergesehen kleiner als merkur und von der,
gab es dann in den achtzigern glaube ich,
die gegenseitigen bedeckt lungen also das von erde ausgesehen der caron sowohl hinter als auch vor dem pluto vorbei luft weil sich gerade die umlauf,
die konstellation der der umlaufbahn oder umlauf ebene mit der erde so sah dass man also von der erde aus den caron vor dem pluto sagen dann sah man also ein ein vergleich der größen,
und,
daraus hat man dann zumindest unter annahme von dichten dann einzeln lassen,
herstellen können und berechnen abschätzen können,
und auch der größten vergleich war dann wichtig da war ziemlich klar was was los ist und dann war auch klar pluto kann nicht verantwortlich sein für die bahnsteige.
Euer zu klein.
Er war zu klein und dann kam die idee auf für den transport auto einer muss er dafür verantwortlich,
und den hat man lange gesucht den hat man gleich ab nach neunzehnhundertzweiundneunzig paypal gesehen ja planet x ja zehn jahre x für unbekannt und für zehn,
genau das war das stichwort und äh ich habe nur paypal gesehen zweiundneunzig wo die ungefähre position sein sollte müssen sollte wo man dann auch beobachtet hat nichts gefunden hat.
Wann also ich kann mich vorher noch daran erinnern dass also bis vor kurzem halt,
man wusste zwar pluto ist da aber ich wusste halt auch erstmal
wir wissen relativ wenig darüber wie er aussieht weil es einfach so weit weg ist und die ganze beobachtung technologie ist zwar halt immer besser geworden aber,
ist halt weit weg und das ding ist nicht sonderlich leucht
stark oder reflektiert nicht viel licht aber man muss ja zumindest dass er eine extrem abweichende bahn hatte im vergleich zu allen anderen planeten also während der sich eigentlich,
die ersten acht planeten mehr oder weniger halt auf derselben kritik bewegen also quasi so eine scheibe insgesamt formulieren die wir glaube ich heute auch zurecht annehmen
weil sie das ergebnis dieser aggressionen scheibe ist also all der staub der sich ebenso über die ja millionen um die erde,
herum gebildet hat nur der pluto ist ja komplett schräg daneben was hat man denn daraus gemacht also.
Das war das war immer das rätsel kratzt sich.
Ja aber was denn überhaupt so naheliegend von einem planeten zu sprechen wenn das ding eigentlich komplett abweicht von allen anderen.
Also das pluto als planet,
benannt wurde und ist rein historisch ist das,
das war einfach neunzehnhundertdreißig so,
wir haben ein neues großes objekt im sonnensystem gefunden das muss ein planet sein.
Und es wandert.
Und es wandert ja genau und es gehört zu diesem system ja und alles jeder war begeistert,
und voll disney war so begeistert über diese entdeckung ja dass er den hund von mickey mouse blutdruck inhalte
der war zwar älter war schon ja in seinen cartoons drin da hieß rover ja aber der war so begeistert dass er den umbenannt hat und,
ja das war das erste was mich nach dem vorbei flug,
jemand vom zdf kinder kanal gefragt an ja was hat der hund von mickey mouse mit bluetooth.
Oder ich wusste es nicht hin und dann habe ich nachgelesen und gut dass ich nachgelesen habe denn,
nach dem vorbei flug bekam ich dann anfragen für,
telefoninterview skype servus und so weit die haben mich alle das gefragt.
Hatte ich jetzt nicht auf meiner liste,
trotzdem vielleicht nochmal was ist denn nun mit dieser schräge also.
Ach so ja ja da waren wir.
Was was hat man denn da rein gelesen oder herauslesen.
Das war es war einfach ein rätsel und es war einfach dann.
Unklar und heute wird man sagen,
okay da draußen sind dann eben diese,
körper so akzeptiert dass eben diese,
in panik nation eben entstanden sind und selbst also die wechselwirkung mit der mit der sonne aber nicht dazu ausgereicht also diese internationale runter zu drücken.
Es gab da keine theorien mit irgendwie kollision oder.
Äh heutzutage heutzutage wird praktisch alles mit kollision erklärt ja alle alle entstehung von mond und und selbst die die monde von von pluto werden durch kollision erklärt und so weiter
aber da bin ich jetzt nicht so drin um zu sagen was jetzt die hypothesen theorien wegen der großen inkarnation waren.
Aber die liebste die nur der pluto um die sonne herum macht die ist ja auch extremer als die der anderen planeten wenn ich das sehe,
ist nicht der sonne nächste punkt,
des pluto sogar näher als der des neptun.
Ja die liegt innerhalb der neptun.
Das heißt die kreuzen sich vielleicht irgendwann mal.
Ja aber nicht in derselben eben
also um momentan ist pluto außerhalb der neptun waren das war auch ein problem für die für die reisenden mission denn das heißt ja pluto geht,
weiter raus und es wird kälter und die befürchtung war dass eben die atmosphäre so kalt wird dass die kollabiert und ausschneiden und dass wir dann vorbeifliegen da ist nix ne.
Wusste man denn schon dass also das war eine annahme dass es dort eine atmosphäre.
Nein das wusste man ja du stern bedecken zum beispiel ja,
das machen wir auch mit extra solarien planeten also zieht der planet vor der stern scheibe vorbei und das stern licht wird dann für diese zeit dieses transit z,
vermindert und es gibt dann so 'ne box in der licht kurve und,
was sie tun ist sie beobachten dann den stern also.
Stern intensität die zeichnen sie auf dann läuft der blut oder,
über diesen stern und wenn er keine atmosphäre hätte dann würde genau an der kante mal jetzt von der fraktion abgesehen,
verständlich herunterfallen und dann wenn auf der anderen seite,
der stern wieder da wir hätten also praktisch sonne so ein loch.
Faire ist das so ein graduell der übergang ja.
Ja genau ja das das ist ganz äh signifikant dass dann der sterne licht also graduell sicher niedrig und dann,
durch den pluto bedeckt wird und da sind hinweis darauf dass dort,
schon außerhalb der eigentlichen kante der der ist der planeten scheibe ein medium existiert welches so die das licht des sterns absolviert radio.
Ich habe noch nicht verstanden warum ist pluto und netto nicht zusammenstoßen können immer wenn du dinge.
Verschiedene ebenen einfach drei.
Die liegen noch schräg zueinander da müsste es doch irgendwann mal dazu.
Ja aber aber die die zwei zwei umlaufbahn die kreuzen sich nicht physikalisch also sie haben keine keine kreuzung wie ihr vorne auf der hafenstraße sondern das ist alles dreidimensional zu sehen.
Aber sie könnten sich zumindest irgendwann mal sehr nahe kommt.
Das tun sie könntest ja und dann gibt's sicherlich auch bahnsteig.
Bad störung dann doch endlich mal da sind sie endlich die bahn störung,
ja dann gab's dann vor mittlerweile knapp dreizehn jahren diese offizielle degradiert drunk des pluto und die manche leute mit einem mit einer träne im knopf loch zur kenntnis genommen.
Nur einige viele.
Viele extrem emotionaler momente mit dem man so gar nicht rechnet in wissenschaftler kreisen oder.
Ja ja ja sie müssen.
Nicht das bild was wir haben von.
Ja ja sie müssen bedenken wir haben seit zweitausendeins eine mission vorbereitet die zu dem neunten planeten fliegen.
Und wir haben sie im januar zweitausendsechs gestartet und im sommer zweitausendsechs ist das kein planet mehr.
So zeigen nicht nur eine dicke radieren von pluto sondern auch ein.
Dass das das.
Die und der mission aber es hat sich abgezeichnet.
Wurde war das eine überraschung.
Willst du nochmal der herr der das gemacht hat der ist doch äh zur umtriebig heiße auf twitter nicht sogar pluto killer,
ja ja.
Oh das weiß ich nicht mehr kann ich nicht mehr erinnern äh er gehört nicht zu meinem persönlichen hast potenzial.
Na gut also die formulierung mike brown war das ne,
also die annahme war ja sozusagen das
dass die kriterien die man jetzt für planeten haben wir irgendwie aktualisiert werden möchten und das halt in allem punkt nämlich dieser frei räumung der bahn der brutto nicht ordentlich mitspielen.
Ja pluto gehört definitiv in den körper gürtel ist man dachte damals oder.
Vor der entdeckung von iris das äh ja damals als eres entdeckt wurde mitteln körper gürtel war und größer als pluto zum zeitpunkt der entdeckung ähm jetzt haben wir ein problem,
wenn ihr es müsste dann auch ein planet sein von der größe.
Weil die sozusagen unterschiedliche bahnen haben ach so ja ok.
Nee von der größe her jetzt erstmal denn wir hatten einen pluto einen planeten und dann,
größer ist ist auch ein planet sein dann und dann taucht eben die frage auf okay wie wollen wir denn jetzt einfach einen planeten definieren und ähm,
die salomon nische definition oder erklärung der war dann ein planet gereist um seinen stern.
Das ist ein doppel stern und hat seine unmittelbare umgebung frei geräumt das gilt für blut und ich.
Aber wie es denn unmittelbare umgebung.
Das kann man jetzt kann man jetzt frei äh sich können sie sich aussuchen aber ich meine der körper gürtel ist natürlich sehr breit.
Ja gut aber ich kann mir das aussuchen ist ja nicht unbedingt die grundlage die man üblicherweise für wissenschaftliche definition heranziehen.
Ja wie auch immer ähm,
aber es kam noch was dazu und das ist natürlich die mittlere dichte von pluto die deutlich niedriger der von terroristischen planeten ist,
und er ist offensichtlich auch kein eis riese,
oder ein gas riese sodass er also eine neue klassiker migration hatte,
einfach von der vom vom inneren aufbau ja die dichte liegt unter zwei gramm pro kubukzentimeter eins komma acht genau,
und das ist schon deutlich anders als das bedeutet dass wir dort auch draußen 'ne andere klasse von objekten.
Vielleicht mal so zum vergleich was sind so die an dichten die man jetzt für den planeten annehmen würde und was haben so asteroiden kometen üblicherweise also wo läuft dann.
Es hängt schwer von der entstehungsgeschichte ab und von der größe zu nehmen die touristischen planeten die haben typischerweise alle eine mittlere dichte zwischen
dreieinhalb und fünfeinhalb gramm publik zentimeter,
er dort fünfeinhalb ist die größte dichte,
in der größenordnung von eins.
Lotto eins komma drei liter eins komma drei,
ähnlich die eis eis riesen wie neptun und orange aus wenn wir zu den kometen kommen,
dann kommen wir zu deutlich kleineren objekten und auch asteroiden,
und äh gibt es so eine grenzgebiet,
äh von mehreren hundert kilometern worunter positivität noch rolle spielt das heißt sie können zwar dort ein gestein s asteroiden haben aber der muss nicht unbedingt eine mittlere dichte von.
Gestern haben wir zwei komma acht oder drei gramm pro kubukzentimeter sondern dort kann deutlich niedriger sein das heißt aber sein aufbau ist dann hoch,
ja jetzt nehmen wir komet siebenundsechzig auf gerade mein co
dort haben wir die masse bestimmt und konnten die mittlere dichte bestimmen und kommenden bestehen aus wasser und sie hat
material,
wasser ist in der mittleren dichte von von einem gramm pro kubukzentimeter silicon care zwischen
zwei komma vier und drei gramm pro zentimeter also wenn das ein solider körper wäre müsste man etwas an mittlere dich daran was deutlich größer als eins ist,
haben wir aber nicht und wir haben null komma fünf gramm pro kubukzentimeter das heißt so ein komet körper ist hoch porös und.
So können sie also nicht unbedingt jetzt von aufbau inneren aufbau,
qualifikation machen erst wenn die eine gewisse größe größe erreicht ist und eigene gravitation kompakte objekte herstellt.
Aber fällt jetzt tut oder so groß heraus also ich meine mit eins komma acht ist er irgendwie schwerer als.
Er fällt fällt von den üblichen planeten ja deutlich heraus und,
nee weil die mittlere dichte kleiner ist,
ja also jetzt ohne er ist ja klar das kleinste objekt überhaupt von wenn wir ihnen jetzt als planeten klassifizieren würden.
Nach geschlagen also mittlere dichte des brutto was war das eins komma.
Eins komma acht ne.
Und der johannes hat eins komma zwo sieben der ton hat.
Ja aber für diese größe ne.
Ach so muss es immer in relation zu größe sitzen okay verstehe.
Denn sie haben ja bei den beim beim orange neptun bei den gas riesen sehr viel leichtes material vom vergast mit dabei aber risiko.
Ok also ich nehme das mal so hin dass das sozusagen außerdem.
Und das heißt dass wir dort eine andere klasse von objekt.
Also er hätte sozusagen damit er in dieselbe klasse von objekten reinfällt hätte er noch sehr viel schwerer sein müssen.
Also wie die restliche plane hin zum beispiel.
Nee also das war jetzt mal aus wie außergewöhnlich ja das wir haben eine neue klasse von objekten und ja aber dann tauchte eben diese die entdeckung von iris auf und das brachte dann okay ist er ist auch ein planet.
Und das brachte dann eben diese revolution in in gang und da gab es dann die,
entscheidung eine neue klasse von objekten zu schaffen die zwerg planeten und das hat er als denn das hatte als konsequenz dass eben auch wester und unseres als mieten,
definiert werden müssen.
Das heißt bei iris ist mein nie so weit gegangen zu sagen das wäre jetzt ein planet kaum war.
Das war der auslöser und er ist nie dazu gekommen also diesen diesen rang ran zu erreichen.
Mythologie da wollten sie iris auch immer nicht dabei haben das ist ja,
schlimm schlimm.
Und äh da gab 's da noch andere objekte die ähnlich groß waren und auch montag den,
sodass also diese diese neue klasse von von zwerg planeten geschaffen wurde was dann schön war.
Als also mit der entdeckung dieser körperbild objekte galt dann pluto als der größte vertreter solcher objekte,
und dann gab 's die entdeckung von iris und tauchen diese probleme auf und was dann schön war während des vorbei flugs,
gab's dann praktisch so ein ein contest zwischen zwei drei gruppen des kamera experiments ja wie groß ist blut
es wurde bis auf dem bild pixel wurde das,
heraus getüftelt und dann stellte sich heraus also pluto ist deutlich größer als,
bisher angenommen glaub zwanzig kilometer war es dann doch,
und größer als iris,
weil die größe von iris ist in der zwischenzeit auch gesunken das haben diese objekt solche objekte immer an sich aber sie werden entdeckt sind riesig groß und je mehr man sie beobachtet desto mehr,
schrumpfen sie das das ist das problem wenn man sich ein vorbei flugs objekte raussucht für eine raumsonde mission asteroiden wie groß ist denn ja fünfzig kilometer ja prima,
und dann wird der beobachtung beobachtung beobachte dann ist er noch nach dreißig.
Und ja also er hat jetzt pluto ist wieder der größte vertreter der der körperbild objekte ja.
Der pluto-a wie das so schön heißt ne genau da gibt's glaube ich so acht jetzt ne.
Genauer zeigen.
Ja also zumindest ich habe so.
Ja ich habe keine.
Listen gesehen aber weiß der geier was da jetzt schon gilt auf der liste war dann auch ihres noch größer als pluto von daher geht das ja auch schon nicht mehr egal also auf jeden fall.
Die zahl der körperbild objekte ändert sich mit jedem tag ist wie an der börse.
Genau vielleicht nochmal so dieser körper gehörte also ich meine man kennt ja den asteroiden gürtel sozusagen der so zwischen den planeten in der gast planeten,
ist wo ein sehr viele astrid sind ab und zu wird auch mal einer rausgeschickt und versucht irgendwie billiger zu spielen mit der erde das miss links glücklicherweise meistens nach dem neptun,
kommt dann halt dieser gürtel was,
was bedeutet denn diese bezeichnung gürtel eigentlich konkret im astronomischen sinne und welche rolle spielen diese planeten da jetzt in diesem konzert.
Ja bei der konzentration der materie ohne attraktion sind,
diese objekte dort in der frühzeit des sonnensystems entstanden aus primitiven material immer noch dort das,
sich wenig verändert hat und als gürtel zu sehen ist dass wir dort also eine eine,
konzentration über einen gewissen,
haben von von von objekten von große anzahl von objekten ja bei der beim inneren asteroiden gürtel gehen wir davon aus dass äh dort,
also das material was ich dort befindet an ist vielleicht ein zehntel erdnüsse sich im inneren asteroiden gürtel befindet,
dass dort eigentlich ein planeten eine chance hat dazu entstehen weil jupiter dort immer dagegen gefruchtet hat mit seinen stört kräften,
und sorgt immer noch dafür dass gewisse lücken entstehen in den resonanzen weil mit der jupiter umlaufbahn.
Elf jahre wenn dort ein,
astrid sich auf einer bahn befindet mit elf geteilt durch eine ganze zahl,
treffen die sich nach nach elf jahren immer wieder an derselben stelle dann kriegt er von jupiter immer ein kick ne und mit der zeit,
geht er eben aus diesen aus dieser bahn raus und da stehen diese lücken und und das also da aufgrund dessen sind also ein ein planeten eine chance hatte zu zu akkreditieren.
Du hast die gürtel sind sein die orte der gescheiterten planeten bildung und die gibt's halt auch jenseits des net.
Ja da gibt's auch theorien und hypothesen das eben mit der entstehung der großen planeten,
sowohl die region zwischen diesen zwei zwei gürteln leer gefegt wurde und,
sowohl in den inneren als auch in den äußeren gürtel heraus katapultiert worden,
aufgrund der man man weiß ja von von kometen auch dass wenn sie an den großen in die nähe der großen planeten kommen dass ihre bahn massiv gestört werden kann zum beispiel showroom oder,
einen historischen zeigen die bahn geändert wurde in die heutige bahn.
War sozusagen der wissens durst so groß dass man mal herausfinden wollte was ist denn nun mit pluto eigentlich genau los und die nasa hat dann die
schöne mission konzipiert und sie da irgendwie schon von,
anfang an in irgendeiner form involviert war haben sie erst später dazu.
Oh so so so einfach war es nicht es war ein holpriger weg dahin.
Gilt wahrscheinlich für die meisten mission ja.
Ja ich hab persönlich an vier oder fünf missionen vorschlägen zum pluto mitgemacht seit mitte der neunziger jahre.
Nicht nur bei der nasa.
Das war meistens mission vorschläge die vom story und präsident kam was nasa dabei ist.
Gab es in europa keinerlei bestreben.
Nee nee nee also für esa hat ein problem,
und esa hat ein problem es hat keine möglichkeiten ein aufs schiff zu bauen das mit.
Mit der notwendigen geschwindigkeit.
Nee das mit der notwendigen.
Radioaktive energie momentan komme ich nicht auf den richtigen namen betrieben werden kann und darf ja für die energieversorgung also rosita.
Die radio nuklearen.
Reset darstellt mit vierundsechzig quadratmeter solarzellen fläche schon.
So dass der oberste ran der möglichkeiten da ja lass uns das lassen sie das mal auf hundert quadratmeter gehen dann kommen sie aber auch nur vielleicht bis zum saturn.
Und dann können sie nicht mehr genügend energie erzeugen mit solarzellen um die äußeren planeten.
Nur die nasa hat radio.
Nur die nase hat eben diese radio mitglied generatoren ja.
Radio.
Das das ist kein atomkraftwerk in diesem sinne sondern einfach nur pellets die nebeneinander liegen hitze erzeugen aus dieser hitze kein strom geworden,
und diese generatoren das haben nur die amerikaner und die russen die können das,
oder dürfen und wie auch immer es war auch ein problem für neo reisende es wurde nicht genügend material hergestellt das mit der brütet in speziellen brüdern
nicht nur für solche mission sondern auch für atombomben und irgendwie tauchte dann,
während der zeit entwicklung seid auf auf wir haben nicht genügend material und dann wurde tatsächlich auch der,
radio generator nicht vollständig aufgefüllt,
beschränk jetzt die lebenszeit dieser mission aber nicht so dass wir sagen können wir können nicht mehr zu blut aufliegen.
Was heißt man wollte eigentlich mit mehr energie fliegen als man letzten endes ist getan hat,
okay also das ist sozusagen das was isa von solchen fernen missionen abhält weil die solar technik da nicht mit.
Ja es ist einfach nur natürliche natürlich grenze ist irgendwo gegeben.
Ja und wie kam es jetzt dann zu uns also wenn wenn es so viele vorschläge gab.
Ja es gab immer es gab diese vorschläge und wir haben mit denen mitgearbeitet auch mit deinem radio experiment und es hat immer eine kosten gescheitert,
es gab ja immer ein kosten raben und dann gab's dann diese diese discovery mission,
die kleine schneller besser billiger sein sollten,
und dann hat das jemand anders gemacht dann hat das vielleicht für sechs leb in,
in colombia von washington mit dem south research institut,
ein vorschlag eingereicht mit dem und,
mein freund lernt heiler von der stanford university hatte dort ein experiment drauf.
Also investigative quasi der leiter der wissenschaftlichen.
Ja genau das ist der haupt wissenschaftler also im gegensatz zu den ganz großen mission wo jedes experiment ein haupt wissenschaftler hat ein pirat haben bei diesem kleinen mission werden von einem,
insgesamt vorgeschlagen das haben wir jetzt auch wieder,
vor zwei wochen das eingerechnet vor einer woche eingereicht und.
Der ist schon allein verantwortlich dafür und er sucht sich seine leute dann und seine industrie,
und sein team,
und einer,
also darf eine kamera an bord spektrum meter war an bord und experiment beantwort für die sondierung der pluto atmosphäre und das kam aus von der stanford university radio science oder radio sondierungsergebnis experiment das ist,
in stanford erfunden worden in den sechzigern und,
in thailand ist praktisch damals die zweite generation gewesen der ähm radio,
seins wissenschaftler die antwort kam,
und er war auch bei uns im team für maß express und venus express,
und wir hatten also verbindung und so kam es dass ich sagte habt ihr schon jemand für die massen bestimmung denn,
was eigentlich nur bekannt war war die systeme masse von pluto also pluto und kauen und alles andere.
Spekulation denn sie brauchen dafür eine gute idee für die dicht.
Nein an so rutschte ich da rein also und hab dann hier also auch mein mein team,
mit eingestellt wir arbeiten zusammen mit der universität der bundeswehr in münchen dort gibt's das institut für raumfahrttechnik und weltraum nutzung,
und mit denen arbeite ich seit fünfundzwanzig jahren zusammen war zuerst professor häusle,
der mich neunzehnhundertvierundneunzig auch am pc angesprochen hat,
ein deutscher spricht mich in amerika an aus dem ist praktisch eine zusammenarbeit über jahrzehnte ähm geworden,
praktisch so eine art kann man sagen familiäre beziehung,
ist das also leute hier aus dieser gruppe sind auch nach münchen gegangen und mit denen arbeiten wir zusammen.
Äh und,
wie so ein experiment funktioniert ist wir würden also am mit der raumsonde,
auf der vorbei flugbahn an pluto vorbeifliegen,
und eine gewissen geschwindigkeit,
und dabei wird ein radio signal gesendet.
Der foto geht jetzt hin und kommt in den anziehungspunkt bereich von pluto und die anziehungskraft von pluto ziehen die raumsonde,
zum planeten,
und damit wird die bahn geändert in geschwindigkeit wird geändert und diese geschwindigkeit änderung sehen sie über den doppelter effekt im in der frequenz des trägers signals das gesendet,
und das können sie das wird dann auf der erde empfangen mit großen antennen.
Und aus dieser.
Verschiebung des trägers ignaz aufgrund der anziehungskraft können sie auf die kraft schließen und dann auf die masse.
War denn zu dem zeitpunkt ist eigentlich schon beschlossene sache.
Ja das war beschlossene sache ja.
Wir reden ja jetzt von welchem zeitraum wo das alles zusammen kam.
Nach zweitausendeins.
Weil die mission haben ja immer ein mega vorlauf.
Ja zweitausendeinhundert zwar auch interessant ja wir haben das der ddr also dem projekt büro in bonn oberklasse äh dann also auch mitgeteilt und die waren auch sehr aufgeschlossen.
Und dann haben wir immer mal kein geld bekommen oder ganz beantragt aber wir haben immer mal wieder reisen,
bezahlt bekommen in die usa zu den teammeetings und dann kurz vor dem start haben wir.
Ein antrag eingereicht dann zur finanzierung.
Oder meint nicht nur hier haben wir den zugestimmt ja sage ich langsam auch zehn jahre.
Oh ich kann mich erinnern und dann seid dann gab's auch ein richtige förderung mit mit personal und.
Was sollte denn jetzt sozusagen und war letzten endes an bord dieser mission also,
ist dann gestartet weil man das.
Zweitausendsechs januar.
Zweitausendsechs und war dann ungefähr zehn jahre unterwegs
rund um diese weite strecke bis zum pluto überhaupt,
in dieser zeit zu schaffen muss das gefährt ja enorm beschleunigt,
werden wenn ich es richtig sehe so sehr wie noch nix was bisher von der erde losgeflogen ist
dass es dann wie gelungen.
Es ging doch mit der träger rakete es war die stärkste träger grete dies damals gab eine atlas fünf,
und er ist direkt in die bahn,
ja nicht direkt zum pluto aber zum jupiter geschossen hat jan zwing bei und jupiter gemacht und ist dann direkt zu.
Einen einzigen swing bei nur ja ok.
Und er ist praktisch keine so wie bei apollo noch einmal um die erde oder sowas äh wurde nicht gemacht und dann direkt,
raus und wofür apollo drei tage benötigte hat reisen sind neun stunden geschafft nämlich die mond bahn zu kreuzen und zum jupiter wars.
Einfach nur kraft der rakete sozusagen.
Das war also das wird beschleunigt auf fünfzehn kilometer pro sekunde und das sind fünf fünfzigtausend kilometer pro stunde das muss man sich erstmal reinziehen.
Und nach dem swing bei.
Da die geschwindigkeit war nicht nicht größer sondern er hat die richtung richtung geändert nicht deutlich größer.
Aber man kann sich doch dann durch den swing bei auch mehr energie holen.
Können sie auch ja.
Aber das wurde da nicht so gemacht da ging es nur darum den richtigen weg zu finden.
Genau und der jupiter wurde erreicht in dreizehn monaten.
Es waren sie in fünf euro in dreizehn monaten oder vier in fast fünf und dann von da ab äh pro jahr zwei bis drei euro.
Also die astronomischen judith.
Astronomie astronomische einheit dass die mittlere entfernung erde sonne und das ist schon eine geschwindigkeit die es wahnsinnig und dann nach weniger als zehn jahren wurde also blut erreichen.
Also wenn man jetzt an wie anfängt davon zu träumen so ah super so schnell kann man zum jupiter kommt dann kann man ja solche mission jetzt auch ganz schnell machen muss dafür taucht ja nicht weil man es zu schnell und könnte dann sozusagen.
Ja sie müssen ja abbrennen wollen sie da so zum jupiter wollen müssen sie abbremsen ja und dann brauchen sie wieder energie und,
yo reisen und zwar ist eine sehr sehr kleine raum sondern wohlgemerkt sehr sehr klein und ist auf die größte rakete oder stärkste rakete geschnallt worden dies damals gab,
ein unterschied ne und es sollte nur rausfliegen.
Spatz mit der kanone geschossen sozusagen.
Das hatte also schon flucht geschwindigkeit aus dem sonnensystem raus und tatsächlich sagen wir mal für so ein kleines experiment ist sag mal fünfzehn kilometer pro sekunde vorbei flugs geschwindigkeit ist schon ein problem.
Genau das wollte ich nämlich gerade darauf hinaus also das bedeutet ja letzten endes dass man mit dieser geschwindigkeit auch letztlich ein auto vorbei rauschen und,
ziel der ganzen maßnahme war er möglichst viel daten zu sammeln über diesen,
körper und wenn man da so schnell vorbei ist also sowieso erstmal nur einen schuss
egal wie schnell man vorbei fliegt es halt wenn man so langsam ist man da in irgendeiner form in einem orbit einsteigen könnte wäre natürlich toll aber jetzt wahrscheinlich dreißig jahre gedauert bis das ding da angekommen wäre,
und das steht natürlich auch erhebliche anforderungen an die instrumente weil die müssen alle in der lage sein mit einer extrem hohen sun bling rät also sehr sehr schnell sehr viele messungen zu machen diese zu speichern,
und ja das vor allem sehr zuverlässig natürlich auch zu tun gut die an.
Definiert auch 'ne minimale entfernung an der sie vorbeifliegen können denn wenn sie eine kamera haben wenn sie da mit fünfzehn kilometer pro sekunde vorbeifliegen an dem objekt und haben eine kamera dann sehen sie erstmal nur das meer ne das ist das bild verschmiert.
Das heißt man konnte nicht so nah ran wie man vielleicht hätte auch wünschen können weil dann wäre halt alles für.
Ja dass das problem tauchte jetzt bei ultimatum auf ne denn die geschwindigkeit war nicht deutlich kleiner.
Also das zweite objekt wo.
Pluto und jetzt letztes silvester denn ähm wir haben gesagt das war so ein so ein,
beispiel ja wo gesagt wurde oh ultimatum kohle da vierzig kilometer groß und je länger man das äh beobachtet hat wird immer kleiner und dann sagt für eine massen bestimmung
wandern die geplanten dreitausend kilometer dann,
unmöglich eine massen bestimmung zu machen tatsächlich ist man dann an dreieinhalb tausend kilometer vorbeigeflogen auch um für die für die instrumente um mehr beobachtung seit auch zu bekommen.
Welche instrumente ist es ist denn mit auf den weg gegeben worden was was wollte man letztlich erfassen.
Ja also es ist nur eine handvoll von instrumenten an bord ist es.
Sind's glaube ich ne.
Ist eben eine kleine raumsonde sie haben gar nicht dem,
möglichkeiten äh viele instrumente wasserreich instrumente schwere instrumente jetzt vom gewicht der aufzubringen meine kamera wir hatten,
u v spektrum meter wir hatten discounter wir hatten also ein staub,
teilchen zähler und ein ein plasma paket was also magnetfeld und den sonnenwind teilchen gemessen hat,
und ähm man wusste eigentlich nicht was ein erwartet ja man.
Ist praktisch ins ins blau hinein geflogen.
Ja war denn die auswahl der instrumente im nachhinein sinnvoll.
Oder hätte man sich jetzt noch irgendwas anderes gewünscht also mehr ist natürlich immer gut aber jetzt sozusagen ein anderes hätte weglassen müssen hätte ein anderes instrument gegeben was man vielleicht stattdessen lieber gehabt hätte.
Ich glaube die auswahl war schon ganz richtig ja einfach deswegen auch was was finde ich eigentlich überhaupt also für das grundsätzlich erstmal für die.
Grundsätzlich expo ration wann war das ein gutes paket.
Ja die kamerad eigentlich schon sehr sehr frühzeitig sehr detailreich fotos geschossen und es wurde mit jeden tag besser,
wir saßen da für zwei wochen in einem kleinen raum und jeden tag wo das neueste bild gezeichnet und äh was ja auch zeit braucht um nach unten zu kommen deswegen waren die,
zeiten zwischen den einzelnen bild bildern ähm ja auch groß also was wir gesehen haben der man konnte gar nicht so viel an datenvolumen herunter herunter funken.
Wie groß war so die daten rate vor der vor dem.
Die daten rate lag er bei hundert pro sekunde.
Vor vor der ankunft.
Überhaupt überhaupt.
Aber es wurde auch dann immer weniger.
Ja aber wir haben ein jahr gebraucht um alles runter zu bekommen und dieses distanz ist dann nicht mehr nicht mehr so so wichtig.
Okay ja hundert pro sekunde das war.
Es ist nicht viel und wenn sie wenn sie heute denken was macht die telekom für werbung,
megabit pro sekunde für ihre internetverbindung.
Sollte andere werbung machen.
Ja
Das können sie sich vorstellen als wenn als wenn wenn man in der steinzeit die ägypter ihre in stein gezimmert.
Das so kam das also dann hier an und deswegen war die zeit zwischen den einzelnen will man hat dann immer auch,
prioritäten gesagt ich will jetzt dieses bild haben.
Wofür war das so wichtig dass das bild schon während des anflug es zu bekommen hatte man da noch irgendwie die gelegenheit auf irgendwas zu reagieren oder war das einfach nur um die eigene einfach die eigenen neugier so ein bisschen zu.
Dass es neugieriges public foundation und auch auch.
Was ja auch wichtig ist also.
Ungeheuerlich wichtig.
Ich denke dass das highlight der letzten jahre war definitiv rosita sie,
kometen also zumindest in europa extrem gut funktioniert
und das ist ja auch international aufgegriffen wurden nicht unbedingt normal jetzt für so eine doch hoch technisch hoch wissenschaftliche mission aber das hat irgendwie die leute fasziniert
und auch bei new visions hatte ich so die die wahrnehmung da war dann so die öffentlichkeit auch irgendwie darauf vorbereitet klar es war ein neues weil irgendwie dieser sagenumwobenen planet die man nie so richtig hart sehen können die ersten bilder natürlich immer was tolles aber es ist dann finde ich auch grade durch diese vorab
bilder ganz gut orchestriert worden und hat dann eben die leute auch richtig mitgenommen.
Absolut die abteilung der nasa sind absolute profis und die waren von anfang an mit eingebunden von anfang an,
sie müssen auch wenn sie solch ein vorschlag mission vorschlag einreichen,
ein ein communications plan haben also das ist praktisch ihre.
Ein teil der bewerbung.
Ja ein ganz wichtiger teil wo reingeguckt wird wenn der schlecht ist fliegen sie raus und das ist ja praktisch dann die wirkung auf die öffentlichkeit denn die nasa sagt ganz ganz eindeutig dass es hier,
steuerzahler geld text bayers moni,
ja der soll auch was davon zu,
und äh aber,
selbst für uns wissenschaftler wir saßen einen raum und dann.
Gab es das erste bild was noch schwarz-weiß war okay sieht besser aus warum hat und äh dann ein tag später wo schon die entfernung deutlich geschrumpft worden.
Jetzt von der letzten woche ungefähr.
Von der ersten praktisch von der anfangsphase ne.
Genau also eine woche vorher.
Ja ja dann sonst geschrei haben sie noch nie.
Als das erste hochauflösend bild kam.
Das war ein toller moment.
Und dann können sie auch noch nicht viel auflösen dann haben sie ein herz gesehen ja oder ein wahl fisch und so wurden dann die die strukturen da bezeichnet also praktisch strukturen auf der oberfläche das herz vom pluto und,
und dadurch dass der pluto ja relativ langsam rotiert haben sie auch nicht so viel unterschiedliches gesehen.
Also die die die sonne flog jetzt auf dem pluto zu aber nicht jetzt direkt mit der sonne im rücken also.
Die sonne war im rücken immer wenn sie rausfliegen haben sie die sonne im rücken.
Ja das ist schon klar aber ich sehe jetzt hier so ein bild da ist dann schon jetzt kein vollmond.
Ja ja wenn sie dann wirklich nahe rankommen und dann an der seite vorbei fliegen dann bekommen sie dann schon halb planeten zu sehen also ein unterschied den terminator unterschied zwischen tag und nacht zeit.
Aber es war ja eh klar dass man sozusagen nur eine hälfte überhaupt wirklich hat sehen können also optisch.
Ja wenn sie genau und langsam rotation sowieso und wenn sie dann vorbeigeflogen sind dann haben sie zurück geschaut und haben wesentlich auf die nacht seite geschaut haben sie in hallo gesehen der atmosphäre,
oder sonnenlicht dann drin gebeugt wurde es war schon ein tolles foto und.
Ja und dann wurde es immer aufgelöst mit dem mit jedem tag.
Was geht anders.
Immer nur ein bild.
Ja was geht aber da so durch den kopf jetzt ist man also zehn jahre warte man seit seit dem start dass es dann irgendwann mal stattfindet meine,
ja auch noch ein leben nebenbei und irgendwann kommt dann dieses projekt und verdichtet sich innerhalb kurzer zeit.
Ja so rosita reisen es nicht so sehr aber rosen wann zweiundzwanzig jahre ist ein halbes berufsleben,
ich war sehr jung damals ich war der jüngste haupt wissenschaftler vor fünfunddreißig jahre alt und,
jetzt bin ich fast vor der pensionierung.
Hätte ja auch alles schief gehen können.
Oh das wäre eine katastrophe gewesen also auch persönlich.
Ja glück gehabt.
Schon eine gewisse dankbarkeit die man da entwickelt.
Ja also die helden die helden das und dann immer die ingenieure und die navigationsleiste im operations zentrum und das sind die wahren helden.
Es war und problematischer süßer gesamte anflug ist ohne probleme gewesen oder gab's irgendwas.
Ja nein es gab vorher mal ein ausfall tatsächlich und raumsonde war wenn ich mir jetzt ein recht erinnere waren war eine lücke drin ja das waren im safe mut und kam aber ganz schnell wieder raus.
Jetzt während des vorbei flugs oder ein paar tage vorher okay.
Ja ja ein paar tage vorher noch zehn tage vorher wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Kreiert eine kleine panik wie immer.
Also selfie-modus dieser modus in den satelliten reingehen wenn irgendwas nicht stimmt und dann wird alles soweit runtergefahren um sich.
Alles runtergefahren die raumsonde geht in eine eine orientierung wo die antenne auf die erde zeigt und dann können sie nur noch bing bing biken,
tag ich bin hier wo seid ihr und dann müssen sie die raumsonde an funken und,
befehle senden also schalte ich wieder hoch und dann kommt ihr raumsonde langsam wieder in den normalzustand.
Und was man warum das passiert.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern es war.
Aber es gab einen grund immerhin man wusste warum so,
also vierzehnter juli zweitausendfünfzehn heute haben wir den fünften juli,
zweitausendneunzehn also genau vier jahre her dass dieser vorbei flug stattgefunden hat ist dann mit,
zwölftausendfünfhundert kilometern abstand also,
am planeten vorbeigeflogen schon gehört es hat alles,
weitgehend funktioniert das heißt alle instrumente waren sozusagen im dauerfeuer beziehungsweise anders herum haben wir halt im dauer betrieb,
gemessen was das zeug hielt die daten in die speicher geschrieben man flog vorbei man hatte relativ früh halt dann denkt man dieses bild ist dann halt ab,
genannten gründen und ist ja auch sagen wir mal für uns glaube ich so als menschen irgendwie erstmal so diese primäre assoziation wenn man haben so okay womit haben wir es denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich zu tun wie interessant ist das worauf es einiger zeit.
Gewartet haben und dir vorbei flug also der mess zeitraum war dann insgesamt wie lang.
Oh das das das fing an zwei wochen vorher.
Zwei wochen vorher bis eine woche nachher.
Na doch solange.
Ja ja das und und während also die wir haben vierundzwanzig stunden gehabt,
größenordnung s mäßig plus minus zwölf stunden um die nächste annäherung wo alles automatisch passiert.
Hatte man keine möglichkeit mehr einzugreifen es wurde alles vorher die operation die zu tun sind,
welches instrument welche lage drehen wir uns es wurde alles in ein sequenz verpackt und hoch gefunkt und lief alles automatisch ab.
Ist ja auch bei der signal weg zu dem zeitpunkt vom pluto bis.
Viereinhalb stunden.
Viereinhalb stunden den vertrag hätte okay.
Also da haben sie hin und zurück und zwei weg laufzeiten und stunden da beginnen sie mit der antenne in kalifornien ja und bekommen das ergebnis dann in spanien,
und da hatten wir ja auch keine möglichkeit ein,
das heißt die die fete vorbei flug später die fand statt,
und äh der countdown er lief dann über die bildschirme und alles verlief im dunkeln es tatsächlich passiert aber es war in echtzeit glaube ich dann,
also die viereinhalb stunden wurden nicht draufgepackt sondern es wurde in echtzeit gefeiert also raum sonnenzeit wenn man.
Okay also man wusste es ist geschehen aber man hatte noch.
Man hat keine ahnung was jetzt passiert ist.
Genau so und dann dauert es natürlich auch noch eine weile also nicht nur dass das erste signal überhaupt eintrifft das
bringt ja erstmal nur die information mit hat geklappt hat nicht geklappt ich schätze mal das dürfte so ziemlich die erste information gewesen sein dann kommen die hübschen bilder und dann den zunehmenden maße eben die ganzen anderen daten bei hundert
pro sekunde und den enormen datenmengen die da angereichert wurden wird ja einige zeit gedauert haben also wie groß ist ungefähr so der da,
satz der jetzt vom pluto in dem vorbei flug erzeugt wurde.
Das sind viele viele gigabytes und die mussten runter.
Das hat dann ein jahr gedauert das alles herunterzuladen.
Da wurde auch priorisiert ja ähm.
Liebes experiment x ja welche teile deiner messdaten willst du zuerst haben und so,
so wir haben also für die sondierung der atmosphäre haben wir auch einen kleinen portionen bekommen.
Und glaubt die letzte portion ungefähr ein dreiviertel jahr nach äh nach dem vorbei.
Was macht man jetzt mit den ganzen
daten also zunächst einmal teilt sich das natürlich dann auf weil es gibt ja quasi für jedes instrument oder für jeden kontext der messung anderes team was dafür zuständig ist die wir natürlich alle so früh wie möglich los arbeiten
bleiben wir vielleicht mal hier so aus der perspektive dieses instituts und ihrer beteiligung jetzt auf welche daten haben sie gewartet wann kam.
Wir hatten also erstmal zwei.
Richtung in die wir uns unser experiment machen einmal wollten wir die masse bestimmen und einmal wollten wir die,
atmosphäre sondieren also die struktur der neutral atmosphäre und der junus fähre von pluto,
und wir wollten die oberflächen temperaturen auf der tag und nacht seite bestimmen,
davon,
liefen die sondierung der atmosphäre und der oberflächen temperaturen über das instrument selber an bord raumsonde,
und auf die daten haben wir gewartet dann und die bestimmung der äh der massen das war ein echtzeit experimente,
bei viereinhalb stunden oder neun stunden rauf runter immer noch in echtzeit experiment,
die also mit dem radio kontakt dem echtzeit radio kontakt mit der raumsonde durchgeführt wurde,
und die diese daten also über die massen bestimmung die bekamen wir praktisch täglich,
zugespielt und haben daraus dann versucht eben die.
Die die doppler sogenannte doppelt kurve also die verschiebung der träger frequenz zusammenzusetzen und dann da aus der masse zu bestimmen.
Das heißt sie haben ihre daten relativ früh bekommen.
Wir haben unsere daten relativ früh bekommt praktisch wie gesagt fast in echtzeit.
Okay alle daten also alle die hier überhaupt relevant sind.
Also das waren praktisch nur eben das funk signal oder die frequenz ist funktional s von zwei wochen vorher bis eine woche nachher.
Wenn man aus dem eigentlichen signal also aus dem eigentlichen träger signal der kommunikation mit der erde daraus selbst die daten gewinnen konnte die man haben wollt.
Genau ja und dass die sondierung der atmosphäre und die oberflächen temperaturen die das wurde so gemacht dass ein radio signal nach zur raumsonde gefunkt wurde,
ähm.
Die dann durch die atmosphäre des pluto ging also es gab zwei zeiten wo das gemacht wurde nämlich,
raumsonde ist eine sogenannte station gegangen,
ist also hinter dem pluto verschwunden von der erde ausgesehen und das radio signal von der erde musste durch die atmosphäre durch beim,
eintritt in die sogenannte organisation und beim austritt aus der wir haben zwei zeitpunkte gehabt und das wurde an bord aufgenommen und auch schon vor ausgewählten.
Also im prinzip auch wie diese fix stern analyse die wir vorher schon besprochen haben nur eben jetzt mit dem signal von der erde aus.
Ganz genau dasselbe beim caron auch also bei dem großen mond auch,
und die oberflächen temperaturen wurden so bestimmt dass die raumsonde gedreht wo die antenne schaut auf dem brote und den caron und,
man in fing mikrowellen signale,
aufgrund der temperatur der oberfläche also sie bekam hier strahlung also wärme strahlung im mikrowellen bereich in die antenne hinein und haben das dann aufgezeichnet vorausgesagt,
und das war an,
darauf haben wir gewartet daneben ne einiges kam recht früh also zum beispiel die erste den eintritt in die organisation das kam sehr früh,
in den ersten monaten weil das eine der,
primären ziele waren auch der der mission die atmosphäre vom foto aber dann für karen und und der austritt der kam die kann man deutlich später.
Das sind ja nur alles so messdaten,
wie soll es nennen von dem man quasi also man hatte vorher einen kleinen plan was man messen wollte wie man's messen wollte und in dem moment wo die daten da waren war dann sozusagen das ergebnis damit auch mehr oder weniger schon da weil,
man sich nicht erst die daten groß anschauen muss um,
herauszufinden wie man aus diesen daten eine information generieren kann also ich hab's dafür einen begriff gibt aber so dieses unmittelbare dieser messung ich würd mir vorstellen hier war dann sozusagen alles bereit ist eigentlich nur noch die daten gefehlt hat und dann hatte,
relativ schnell ein ergebnis während sicherlich die mission kommen wir auch gleich nochmal drüber sprechen auch informationen an sich gewinnt also zum beispiel einfach überhaupt das optische bild dann muss man erstmal drauf schauen und dann entsteht ja überhaupt erst neue fragen und dann,
dann taucht man sozusagen so 'ne wissenschaftliche zweite forschung quasi ein herausfinden so ah okay da sind,
alles so und so aus lass doch mal hier genauer reinschauen um daraus dann schlau zu werden.
Äh ja also.
Wir wissen ja wie wir unsere daten zu massieren haben ja wir haben also nur darauf gedacht wartet dass das sogenannte telematik trieb paket mit unseren daten dann und auftauchte das wurde dann im operationen zentrum entpackt,
und wir konnten uns dann ein besser lesbar pfeil herunterladen und das wurde dann ähm protestiert
wir brauchen dann die aktuellste traktoren die also die vorbei flugs,
flugbahn die war notwendig um die war auch relativ früh da,
und dann wurde daraus dann ein profil,
der temperatur der dichte und der neutral teilchen zahl als funktion der höhe der pluto atmosphäre erstellt,
und es ist herausfordernd gewesen weil,
die dichte der atmosphäre von pluto ist sehr sehr sehr sehr hab ich genug sehr dünn,
ungefähr pascal in der größe.
Im vergleich zur erde die bei.
Ja die bei einem ein bar liegt fünfzig zehntausend zwanzigtausend pascal.
Also ein fünfzigtausend der erdatmosphäre mal so gruppe waren daumen geteilt.
Und das geht an den rand der auflösung eines solchen experimente das heißt man brauchte eine.
Einen niedrigen rausch hintergrund und untergrund um dann das signal herauskitzeln zu können dass unsere kollegen in stanford also wirklich gut gelungen kam also ein,
temperatur profil sehr kalte atmosphäre,
bis in circa zwanzig dreißig.
So was wissen wir denn jetzt,
über den pluto was wir vorher nicht wussten außer dass er ein bisschen größer ist als gedacht also,
fangen wir mal mit dem mit dem optischen eindruck an haben wir schon angesprochen diese herz muster und so weiter hat ja alle leute gleich äh total in äh aufregung gebracht weil er einfach aussah,
das hat auf jeden fall geholfen was was war denn an diesem bild,
an diesem ersten hochauflösend den foto des pluto schonmal aufregend und was womit hat man so vielleicht nicht rechnen.
Erstmal.
Man hat ja im prinzip neue strukturen gesehen.
Praktisch an an die farben unterschiedliche licht reflektieren hell dunkel was nachher ein bisschen eingefärbt wird aber diese hohe variabilität in den anbieter strukturen die war,
außergewöhnlich also was war überraschend bedeutet ja das ist ja das material an der oberfläche was ja eine gewisse reflektionsfrage fähigkeit dann hat,
und dass es ist alle verschiedene materialien sein müssten die dort abgelagert und zwar.
Also man wusste sozusagen sofort okay das ist jetzt kein uniformen körper der einfach nur so langweilig da so.
Ein langweiliger eis oberfläche oder irgendwie sowas was auch immer der ursprung des eises ist.
Vorher anlass zu glauben dass man so ein ergebnis bekommen würde oder war das einfach komplett offen.
Das war nicht ganz komplett offen man hatte ja,
zehn jahre vorher weiß nicht mehr genau mit habel,
pluto beobachtet und hatte schon strukturen gesehen,
aber derartig grob.
Meine hoffnung war sozusagen als eine ahnung.
Also dass da dass das nicht uniform war hatte man schon die idee.
Aber nicht so.
Nicht so dann man sah ja detaillierter man sah ja dann auch,
topografie ja schon gebirge,
etwas aus dem eis hervor luken und krater was auch immer jetzt diese kater sind oder was der ursprung dieser karte ist.
Im detail und das war schon schon erstaunlich also wenn wir ein körper gehabt hätten dessen atmosphäre.
Kollabiert worden wäre aufgrund der kalten temperaturen dann wäre das wahrscheinlich alles,
die gesamte tupperware eventuell die gesamte topografie bedeckt gewesen,
in dem sinne hatten wir glück gehabt dass es noch nicht so weit geschehen ist das also die atmosphäre total kollabiert es waren die befürchtung vorher also müssen jetzt fliegen sonst kommen wir,
zu einem zeitpunkt an wo pluto so kalt geworden ist dass die atmosphäre.
Wie weit weg war denn pluto von dem sonne nächsten punkt also wenn man jetzt.
Spontan weiß ich es es jetzt nicht aber er war schon außerhalb der neptun waren.
Spontan muss ich's nachgucken.
Das heißt also wie lange das her dass dieser sonne nächste punkt erreicht wird also von fünfzig jahre hundert jahre also paar jahre okay.
Oh nee nee nee nee ja also zehner ja.
Also theoretisch hätte man jetzt sozusagen zehn jahre vorher schon geld und das technische die technischen voraussetzungen und.
Hätte man sogar gehabt hat man sozusagen verpasst.
Definitiv also wir waren ja schon in den frühen neunzigern dabei so ein solch ein mission vorschlag zu mal haben wir auch gemacht,
ist aber aus geld gründen dann abgelehnt worden dann werden wir deutlich wahrscheinlich noch zu einem zeitpunkt angekommen wo er innerhalb der netto m danke.
Und hätte das bedeutet dass es sehr viel anders ausgesehen hätte als jetzt.
Wahrscheinlich ja das ist auch eine sache die bei kometen so so ist oder bei den centauri euren.
Zentren ist zum beispiel ist ein center ist ein ähm ein objekt was ähm äh jenseits der saturn bahn ist oder nicht jedenfalls noch innerhalb der saturn waren,
weit entfernte als die typischen jupiter,
kommenden familien ja wo sie zum beispiel nehmen wir wieder siebenundsechzig co der appell hat von fünf astronomischen einheiten,
da kollabiert.
Also der sonne.
Das fenster punkt das ähm das heißt sie haben dort den den den nackten nukleos kometen nukleos kehrt kometen kern näher sie jetzt auf der bahn zur sonne kommen,
gas aus zunächst mal kohlenmonoxid und wasser erst ab,
das heißt sie können die können nicht erwarten dass sie dann bei pluto in der atmosphäre noch wasser finden was das.
Also obwohl diese objekte so furchtbar weit wechseln atmen die doch ganz schön ein und aus mit ihrer sonnen nächsten und.
Aber es sind andere andere moleküle andere gase als typischerweise im inneren sonst.
Und die zehn dauern das sind so die objektive quasi mit dem saturn so.
In der größten auto motivatoren also chiron von dem wird ja,
spekuliert dass wir ebenfalls ein riesiger komet wäre weil er so so eine starke koma auch entwickelt ne oder neunundzwanzig pisch was man wachmann von dem kann man nicht erwarten dass,
an seinem kometen fernsehen punkt also irgendwie mit wasser in seiner koma auftaucht.
Ok also wir haben pluto zumindest nicht zu spät erwischt um noch begeistert zu sein von den ergebnissen und man hat jetzt gesehen okay,
es gibt ja viele strukturen es gibt berge es gibt also man man schaut da drauf und denkt sich sofort zu war ein planet also ein bisschen so die erwartungshaltung erfüllte man glaube ich
irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen im kopf hat und da sind irgendwie die
was nicht saturn sitz war irgendwie ganz besser aus aber ist halt im wesentlichen alles nur irgendwie gas hier sieht man auf einmal wieder strukturen woraus besteht denn pluto nun allen gestein planet ist es ja nicht und gas
auch ist es nur eis ist sozusagen reine eis wüste besteht das ding nur aus wasser oder was.
Da ist natürlich schon gestein mit drin sieg hart material ist dabei ja aber äh aber.
Wesentlichen an der oberfläche sehen sie eise ja von verschiedensten moleküle ähm von verschiedenen von verschiedensten spezies.
Da haben wir also zum beispiel auch eis wasser eisberge die also in metallen oder kohlenmonoxid,
sehen schwimmen aufgrund der kleineren dichte gucken die hier raus.
Das könnte man erkennen.
Ja was kommt man erkennen.
So ein bisschen wie titan der mondi saturn der auch so unheimlich ehrt ähnlich außer.
Kann man nicht miteinander vergleichen,
kaltes auf beiden ganz ordentlich.
Ja aber titan hat eine sehr dichte atmosphäre sodass damit auch seine ähm,
und temperaturen auf der oberfläche das also andere vorgänge da da sind ne da friert nix aus bei so einer dichte atmosphäre,
da da regnet es er metall irgendwie sowas ja da möchte ich nicht sein.
Was ist noch dran am pluto also was was weiß was war was weiß man jetzt sozusagen aus dem aus dem daten was kann man was kann man über diesen körper jetzt definitiv sagen.
Ja man hat jetzt eine idee darüber welche materialien eigentlich bei der entstehung des frühen sonnensystems da vorhanden waren und aus dem diese objekte dann entstanden sind und das kann man jetzt weiter
projizieren auf die anderen körperwelten objekte und,
bekommt dann auch so eine entstehungsgeschichte oder auch,
kondensationskerne richte äh im frühen sonnensystem ne,
wir haben also hier,
auch mit ultimatum hole primitive objekte aus der frühzeit der sonst.
Und das ist super setting weil man die sonst normalerweise halt so nicht vor die kamera.
Das das geht also direkt es geht direkt in die modelle für die entstehung des des sonnensystems rein.
Wenn das jetzt vier jahre her ist mit dem ganzen daten also jetzt sind ja alle daten.
Alle daten sind da ja ja.
Nach einem jahr sozusagen oder anders ausgedrückt,
man hat jetzt drei jahre zeit gehabt auf dem vollständigen daten satz zu arbeiten haben sie so ein bisschen im blick was für studien rausgekommen sind was für untersuchungen gemacht wurden die jetzt sozusagen den pluto sich mal ganz genau angeschaut haben was da.
Können sie den überblick verlieren weil jetzt alles so ins detail geht dass sie eigentlich gar nicht mehr,
da dran bleiben wenn's nicht direkt ihr gebiet betrifft ja so in der geologie bin ich nicht drin und was da jetzt die geologie als x-wing empfinden ich kann nicht frühzeitig.
Was wollen sie denn extra ding.
Also ich fand schon die hochinteressant dass wir tatsächlich die atmosphäre haben auflösen können äh und eine struktur,
fast so there wäre darstellen konnten.
Also überall dieselbe temperatur.
Zumindest eine funktion der höhe fast und wir haben die oberflächen temperaturen eine sehr kalte oberfläche der größeren von fünfzig kelvin vierzig fünfzig kelvin,
verdammt kalt um und das also sowohl tag und nacht oberflächen temperaturen gar nicht so sehr variiert.
Ist das so überraschend ich meine so weit draußen hat ja die sonne nicht mehr viel einfluss.
Ja auch die die rotation von sehr langsam größenordnung sechs tage,
sollte eigentlich eine gewisse lackierung eintreten mit.
Also sechs erden tage für eine rotation sozusagen.
Sechs tage für eine rotation und dann noch im doppel synchron rotation mit mit caron das heißt sowohl pluto,
als auch caron rotieren mit derselben periode als auch caron revolutioniert mit derselben periode um blutung ist also einmalig im sonnensystem,
und das durch gezeiten effekte passiert,
und es ist gar nicht so einfach dies dies zu machen.
Das kennen wir ja vom ja das kennen wir ja vom erdbeermund system der mond hat ja dieselbe rotation periode wie revolution periode erde hat das gemacht mit ihren gezeigten kräften auf dem mond.
Also wir sehen immer dieselbe seite weil das.
Immer dieselbe seite das heißt vom vom vom pluto aus sehen sie den karo nur wenn sie einer bestimmten stelle stehen und sehen ihn immer.
Von dieser stelle.
Wenn montag immer da ist und immer dieselbe seite okay.
Ein munter immer da ist und sie sehen immer derselbe seite äh und die der mond macht das mit der erde auch,
führen auch noch länger aber irgendwann wenn das universum nicht mehr existiert wird es dann auch mal so.
Solange wird das noch dauern aber wir können das messen dass das passiert also das der tag wird immer länger und der mond entfernt sich von der erde das ist alles messbar ne.
Ist ja dann weiter geschossen weil,
was erstmal fliegt im universum das hält so schnell nichts auf man hat also diese fünfzehn kilometer pro sekunde einfach beibehalten weil daran ändert sich ja sozusagen erstmal nichts wenn er keine größeren widerstände sich in den weg stellen und davon
gibt es leider nicht so viel und dann hat man ja nach relativ schnell glaube ich beschlossen okay also erstmal festgestellt,
funktioniert noch alles super,
sehr viel treibst du also mehr treibstoff zumindest noch vorhanden als gedacht also obwohl weniger dieser radio nuklear batterien dort untergebracht wurden als ursprünglich geplant war.
Ja erstmal energie und dann auch treibstoff ne für die düsen man muss ja eine änderung der flugbahn um jetzt irgendwo anders hin zu fliegen.
Wenn alles so durchgeplant ist warum ist das so ein großes fragezeichen wieviel am ende noch über ist wenn man eigentlich schon vorher genau weiß wo man lang fliegen will.
Ja dazu also sollte man navigator und kreuzingen als auch ihn ein gottes status sorten ja also.
Sie berechnen dir eine flugbahn,
und zu berechnen mit dieser flugbahn wieviel treibstoff sie brauchen die navigator den gehen hin und nehmen dann immer eine reserve an.
Und erst nachdem also dann zum beispiel ein manöver beendet worden ist stellt man fest ob man liegt.
Voll auf der geplanten traktoren wir brauchen die reserve nicht mehr ich kann ihnen da als beispiel erzählen die der staat von rose da wurde ja um dreizehn monate verschoben und die ursprüngliche rosita mission die hatte,
so und jetzt wurde die mission um dreizehn monate verschoben und die navigator und kam an und sagt,
wir haben kein treibstoff um irgendwelche spielchen asteroiden gürtel zu machen,
großes geschrei,
man hat sich darauf geeinigt okay wir schauen mal nach dem start stellte sich heraus dass die ariane rakete,
rosita derartig präzise auf ihre ersten orbit gebracht hat das die ganze reserve.
Die korrektur nach dem start einfach nicht gebraucht wurde.
Nach dem start frei wurde und man an zwei asteroiden damit verpflichten.
Nur dadurch ist es.
Dadurch ist das ermöglicht worden und ähnliches ist hier auch also navigator nehme ich mache selber sondern die werden dann freigegeben und dann hat man plötzlich genug raum für für irgendwelche spielchen.
Also ist das im prinzip ein kann man kann sagen wenn so viel,
guten des guten starts und der guten fortführung und planung der entsprechenden korrektur baden.
Manchmal sind korrektur manöver so präzise dass die nächste das nächste korrektur manöver abgesagt wird,
und deswegen also die rosita navigator und die werden gekreuzt sigt worden da als sie das verkündet haben ja und als dann der staat vorbei war und,
plötzlich hundertachtzig meter pro sekunde frei wurden für irgendwelche spielchen.
Niemand ist besser und ja und das.
Man muss ja nicht wo wohin man jetzt eigentlich unterwegs ist beziehungsweise man man man kannte nichts,
oder zum zeitpunkt der staat der mission gab es noch kein objekt von dem man annahm dass man es unter umständen erreichen könnte wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Es gab sogar bis zwei jahre vor blutung kein kein objekt man hat dann
man muss ja frühzeitig in solche planung hineingehen und auch äh anträge stellen dann antrag ging ja nase wenn wir an pluto vorbeigeflogen sind und dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich noch so viel treib schon so viel leistung wir könnten noch das und das tun
zum beispiel an einem anderen vorbeifliegen das geht an die nase und da brauchen sie ihnen objekt und,
zweitausenddreizehn war nix sie,
flogen ja aus dem sonnensystem heraus und in eine richtung die ging erst ernährung richtung zentrum der galaxis das heißt.
Wenn sie nach einem körperbild objekt suchen suchen sie das vor dem hintergrund der des galaktisch zentrums.
Da ist natürlich.
Da viele sterne.
Viele sterne.
Und dann das signal eines herauszusuchen ist herausforderung.
Also es ist nicht so dass man da nichts gesehen hat sondern man hat sehr viel gesehen aber rauszuhalten was davon sozusagen jetzt ein ein objekt ist was wirklich noch zu uns gehört und sich daran bewegt das ist die eigentliche schwierig.
Genau und zweitausendvierzehn hatte man dann drei objekte die man erreichen.
Und die waren,
die geschichte die muss man eigentlich einzeln erzählen das
man hat also es gab ja auch gastronomen im team und die hatten ja ihre beobachtung teleskop zeiten und so weiter und die haben gesucht und besucht und äh was sie natürlich machen wenn sie ein objekt finden müssen sie die bahn bestimmen,
ich muss ja wissen.
Wo geht das hin wo kommt das her.
Geht das sehen und wo man sich wie muss ich vorbeifliegen und so weiter dann hatte man,
kandidaten etwas so und,
tja wie können wir die bahn bestimmen habe,
und dann ging das also ein antrag an sabbeln space institut und mit beobachtung seiten die hätten,
praktisch andere programme mit dem teleskop für wochen erschlagen,
und das ging natürlich nicht durch und da gab es dann zunächst mal zeit sogenannte direktor seid,
da hat der direktor vom institut hat seine eigene,
beobachtung zeit mit dem beste des club und die hat eine gewisse,
davon zur verfügung gestellt hat gesagt wenn er in dieser zeit was findet dann schauen wir mal.
Wie ist das verhältnis zwischen zeit die man gerne gehabt hätte und seitdem,
das ist dann wieviel.
Bestimmt einzuziehen oder man hat ein paar paar tage beobachtung zeit bekommen.
Du hast schon relativ viel ist für so ein wild rund alle drauf holen.
Und dann hatte man tatsächlich da ein objekt oder kandidaten gefunden,
und hatte dann also auch portionsweise dann weitere zeit bekommen zur bahn bestimmung und dann hatte man eben zweitausendvierzehn neunundsechzig ausgewählt einfach an.
Keine andere kein anderer grund ist da.
Ja klar also ich meine da war dann war es so,
ich blicke auch gerade auf so filmchen wo man das ding so vorbeifliegen sieht hinter vor allem gewitter von sternen also da kann man schnell raus ausmachen dass das alles,
problematisch es fallen das ding leuchtet ja natürlich selber nicht und es nochmal viel viel,
einer heißen pluto da überhaupt was zu entdecken.
Ja fünfzehnter sechzehnter ist in ordnung.
Wow so das heißt man wusste da ist was das fliegt in eine richtung in einer geschwindigkeit,
den fans nochmal so in der bahn korrigieren kann um eben ein weiteres rondo herzustellen das ist ja dann auch gelungen,
man ist glaube ich so dreitausendfünfhundert kilometer oder sowas.
Kilometer.
An dem objekt vorbeigeflogen natürlich viel viel viel kleiner noch als der pluto mit instrumentalisieren die eigentlich für die beobachtung das pluto gedacht war wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so genau gepasst hat wir hatten ja vorhin schon,
angedeutet dass das vorbeifliegen.
Ja ja deswegen.
Schwammig schwammig.
Also die instrumente passen schon ja,
zunächst war ja angedacht dreitausend kilometer entfernung von zu fliegen ich habe gesagt wer besser bei der größe mit zweitausend da können wir auch eine massen bestimmung machen,
und dann wird 's raus geschoben nach dreieinhalbtausend einfach für die instrumente,
und genauigkeit der bahn also die war immer noch so hoch dass man eventuell angst hatte,
die kamera nicht präzis genug pointen zu können also ausrichten zu können dass er tatsächlich im blickfeld ist,
das hat aber alles funktioniert und alles gepasst und dann kam also die überraschung über die form.
Also die licht kurve war erstmal langweilig,
stellte sich heraus also wenn wenn man jetzt das jetzt auf diese form also diesen diesen schneemann da.
Vergleicht war die licht kurve relativ langweilig.
Also licht kurve im sinne von die langzeit beobachtung durch habel.
Sie haben sie haben ja schon beim anflug haben sie drauf geguckt.
Genau und stellt sich raus dass die rotation achse genau von reisen schaute und dass sie praktisch.
Keine änderung in dem in der in der form in der licht kurve gesehen haben,
und dann wurde es aufgelöst das war damals wie bei rose als dann der erste bild vom kometen kern ist relativ weiter entfernung kam solche kleinen objekte scheinen alle.
Rechtskurve aufgemacht zu sein was die formel.
Ja man spricht auch von einem inneren objekt bei thema tula also aus quasi so aus zwei noch eins sind also im prinzip so zwei einzelne körper die in irgendeiner form sich mal angenähert und dann verbunden haben ist das eigentlich bei,
gerade zu.
Ja hab ich lange dafür gebraucht ja wir tan war einfacher.
Das wäre schön gewesen dem rosita kometen gilt das eigentlich auch also ein besonderes objekt aber da war ja im prinzip auch so eine.
Die diskussion ist da die diskussion ist da wir meinen eventuell nicht,
weil die mittlere dichte von beiden kopf und leib von dieser kosmetischen ende erst ernährung gleiches das heißt entweder haben sie sich.
In unmittelbarer nähe zunächst aus demselben material geformt und sind dann,
haben sich angenähert und das müssen dann relativ geschwindigkeiten sein die sind sehr sehr sehr klein das sind dann also in der größenordnung meter pro sekunde oder sowas ne ansonsten zerstören sie sich,
aber um dann haftet so bleiben sie es müssen noch sehr geringe.
Sowieso zwei seifenblasen die so zusammen kleben.
Genau und eine ähnliche ähnliche ideen nachhinten.
Könnte man denn hier die dichte bestimmen irgendeiner form oder war das.
Da gibt's also auch nur spekulationen über die dichten also was sie brauchen die masse dafür ne also da gibt's dann auch wieder strukturen,
mit topografie wobei also die spekulation auch dahingehen dass wir hier so eine attraktion,
wie bei kometen eventuell wie bei kometen körpern haben dass sie also einige größere teile haben die sich dann,
miteinander verschmelzen und das da eventuell die topografie dieser einzelne körper aus die top derzeitige topografie ist diese sehen,
das bedeutet auch dass so ein körper brüste aus,
wir wissen von schulen und das also die positivität in größeren von siebzig prozent ist.
Das heißt sie haben in dem volumen siebzig prozent lehrer.
Und der rest ist mit dem material aufgebaut ne also wenn wenn es dazu kollision kommt mit hohen geschwindigkeiten,
geht das ans zerstörungspotential,
andererseits bei niedrigen geschwindigkeiten können solche körper kollision auch besser verarbeiten denn zunächst mal wird die werden die leere räume kontaktiert und.
Haben sie quasi so eine knutsch zu.
Man sieht ja nicht nur aus wie ein schneemann kann auch sein dass man sich das von der positivität her auch wieso nicht stark zusammengedrückt schneebälle vorstellen kann die sich.
Ja man sieht ja auch an der halskrause der anführungsstriche oben halskrause dass dort schon andere strukturen sind das heißt also eventuell auch andere oberflächen.
Weil sich da zusammengedrückt hat.
Weil es sich da kontaktiert hat denn lass die kontaktstelle.
Das war ja jetzt im prinzip auch nochmal eine,
unglaubliche leistung oder also das sozusagen jetzt nochmal nach zu liefern mit einem objekt was man wenige jahre voll gar nicht kannte dementsprechend natürlich auch weniger vorlauf
das ist ja dann eine leistung sowohl dieser bahn berechnung,
nicht in der beobachtung dieses objektes und dann natürlich dann auch wieder
der emissionsfreie führung der bahn korrektur von jetzt liegt das ding weiter,
jetzt gibt's wahrscheinlich erstmal kein objekt was man jetzt noch theoretisch von dem man weiß dass es da ist was man theoretisch erreichen.
Also wenn unsere astronom da nicht was äh noch geheim halten gibt's momentan kein objekt kein kandidat.
Wird denn so aktiv danach gesucht mit habel.
Es wird schon gesucht ja was zugang hat.
Mit allem was okay aber gibt's irgendwie große auswahl also ich habe quasi prädestiniert.
Es gibt eine große teleskope in dubai und.
Auch vom boden aus okay.
Ja vom boden aus auch ja da haben die zugang zu,
müssen die direkten antrag stellen und wo sie genau hinschauen wollen dann müssen sie erfolgsaussichten auch angeben.
Das heißt man benutzen erstmal die bunte des gruppe umzuschauen ist vielleicht überhaupt irgendwas da wenn man da sagt okay das riecht hier wirklich nach dem ergebnis dann würde man nochmal bei habe.
Dann haben sie reale chance mit habe was zeit zu bekommen.
Okay verstehe also kann sein kann kann auch nicht sagen.
Es kann doch nicht sein ja aber was auf jeden fall gemacht wird ist man fliegt weiter,
denn es gibt ja ein plasma paket an bord plasma paket bedeutet,
das ist die untersuchung des sonnen windes und das geht im.
Zusammen mit äh der untersuchung des magnetfeldes ist in der magnetfeldes was,
von der sonne kommt und dem sonnenwind ist also der partikel strom der von der sonne ausgesendet wesentlichen,
proton und helium kerne und elektronen,
deren dichter der geschwindigkeiten deren täten und dann natürlich wenn sie weiter rausfliegen was ja auch vorher die zwei machen noch machen wo ist die ganze sonnensystem,
also sogenannte helios pause wo komm ich.
Wo endet der einfluss der sonne.
Ja genau wo wo komme ich in den industriellen raum.
Wie lange kann denn also angenommen wird es kein weiteres objekt mehr in angriff genommen,
was ist denn die erwartungen wie lange man mit uns also wie lange das ding jetzt quasi in dem modus weiter fliegen kann wie lange reicht der strom der treibstoff ist.
Treibstoff braucht.
Irrelevant also wie lange reicht es an der strom und wie lange ist eine kommunikation noch möglich wir wissen ja von,
auch mit siebziger jahre technologie kommt man da noch sehr weit und da ist es ja sicherlich viel weiterentwickelt wie viele jahre kann sozusagen da noch wissenschaftlicher gewinn erzeugt wird.
Also wenn man sich auf das plasma paket reduziert und auf die,
das notwendigste in der operation der raumsonde wahrscheinlich zehn jahre.
Zehn jahre und wie weit würde dann würde dann irgendwie im bereich stoßen.
Wenn sie derzeitige geschwindigkeiten annehmen von sagen wir mal maximal drei euro pro jahr können sie noch dreißig astronomische einheiten draufpacken wo sie jetzt sind wir waren jetzt bei.
Du bist dreizehn ne.
Bluetooth foto war zweiunddreißig.
Dreiunddreißig okay.
Jetzt ultimatum fahre irgendwo in den vierzigern und kommen sie auf die siebziger achtziger astronomische einheit.
Da ist auch ganz fix unterwegs.
Ja sollte bei hundert mindestens liegen.
Derzeit im abstand.
Hundertsechsunddreißig eins ist einhundertsechsundvierzig entfernt und schafft jedes jahr nochmal drei komma sechs ordentlich.
Und weil bei spekuliert man darüber dass man bereits im interdisziplinären raum ist.
Das ist gar nicht so genau definiert wo das ist ne.
Es kommt auf die signaturen an im im plasma bereich also sind zum beispiel die solarien,
der solange plasma strom doch dominant oder sie schon intersolar das material,
was mit temperaturen zu tun hat was mit dem magnetfeld zu tun man,
beim übergang vom planetarium zum klaren magnetfeld und,
wie schnell das funktioniert was weiß keiner gibt's nur spekulationen darüber das kann ganz langsam passieren und es wurde auch schon ein paar mal angekündigt dass es so ist und,
und.
Kann das sein dass man dass man irgendwann entscheidet okay alles klar den treibstoff brauchen wir jetzt für keine bahn korrekturen mehr korrektur sind und jetzt egal jetzt ballern wir einfach den ganzen treibstoff den wir haben um weitere geschwindigkeit aufzunehmen ne weil es nicht so viel bringt oder.
Würde keinen sinn machen sie haben schon die flucht geschwindigkeit und.
Das das würde jetzt also großartig nicht mehr viel machen wenn sie jetzt noch ein kilometer pro sekunde draufpacken also.
Na ja ich meine wenn man nur noch zehn jahre hat und äh umso weiter man kommt umso mehr erkenntnisse von draußen kann man ja dann reinholen oder.
Also also ich wüsste nicht ich wusste nicht wie viel man noch da jetzt noch mit welche wie die geschwindigkeit noch vergrößert werden könnte.
Lieber auf spahn falls du noch irgendwie was spannendes vorbeikommt.
Naja.
Da müssen wir eigentlich am ende aber ich wollte nochmal äh da wir uns ja eigentlich die ganze zeit in diesem trans neptun zwischen bereich tummeln,
ja nochmal so einen anderen mythos kurz ausgraben vor einigen jahren gab's ja ein pippa was sozusagen,
es war dieser selbe mike brown der schon den pluto degradiert hat.
Mit seinen kollegen studio rausgebracht hat mit
er hat sich jetzt mal diese ganzen transfer politischen objekte,
angeschaut ich weiß gar nicht wie viele das mittlerweile sind auch,
viele hundert also da ist man man man sieht einfach immer mehr umso mehr man da hinschaut umso mehr sieht man da herumfliegen natürlich ist nicht alles so aufregend und groß wie irgendwie iris oder der pluto kleinere objekte aber eben
viele viele viele viele und was wohl festgestellt wurde ist dass die nicht gleichmäßig verteilt sind
das hat irgendwie schlagzeile da ist irgendwie an einer stelle ist mehr,
und an einer anderen stelle irgendwie nicht und das ist ja irgendwie nicht unbedingt das was man jetzt so erwarten würde vom,
zum weltraum und vor allem diffusen reste bereich von dem wir ja schon gesprochen haben und sagen,
gürtel sozusagen mit all dem was so rausgeworfen und nicht weiter verarbeitet wurde von anderen planeten
was ich da halt tunnel da würde man ja erwarten dass das dann so eine random vierte verbreitung hat und die these war ja nun die ja okay gut
kann ja gut sein wir haben das mal nachgerechnet was wäre wenn wir da nochmal so einen riesen planeten haben den planeten nummer neun der da mit
keine ahnung zweihundertfünfzig abstand also so richtig weit draußen
rumlungern hat in einer riesigen lips e hier quasi unser sonnensystem noch in einem bereich ergänzt wo wir im derzeit noch nicht hinschauen können weil wir vor allem nicht wissen wo genau wo wir hin,
schauen sollen weil man weiß ja nicht wo der dann genau wäre.
Was ist von sowas zu halten ist das alles nur kaffeesatz lesen frei oder hat das irgendwie vielleicht substanz.
Ich würde sagen ich glaub die statistik ist nicht hoch genug ja äh wir haben ja auch 'n beobachtung mit drin äh wie gesagt,
reisen fliegt jetzt in richtung galaktisch das zentrum um dort objekte zu finden schauen sie auf die vielen sternen galaktisch im zentrum dementsprechend wenn sie eine gegensätze richtung gucken werden sie,
mehr körperbild objekte finden weil es einfach einfacher ist genau sie haben also nicht den ganzen hintergrund mit den störenden sternen ähm,
und ich weiß ich kann das nicht so im detail dass ich jetzt weiß wie sie diesen beobachtung preis mit rechnung getragen haben,
dadurch dass auch die umlaufbahn natürlich viele viele hundert jahre sind in diesem,
für die für diese körperbild objekte dort in sagen wir mal selbst über zehn jahre,
bahn störungen ausfindig zu machen insbesondere mit den fehlern ist,
schon eine herausforderung also ich halte dieses paper für mich ja äh,
ist natürlich eine spekulation die ankommt.
Und damit kann man sich natürlich dann auch sein publikum schaffen,
aber ich halte das schon sagen wir mal für zu früh dafür was man bisher über,
den körper gürtel weiß ja wir haben das erste objekt unserer zweiundneunzig entdeckt ja das ist siebenundzwanzig jahre.
Das ist quasi auch vorhin.
Ja und dementsprechend haben diese objekte nicht viel äh.
Strecke auf ihrem eigenen orbit zurückgelegt ne.
Um jetzt präzise darzustellen zu können äh wie weit weiche ich von diesem objekt von diesem orbit ab von einem,
normalen arbeit oder sowas ja da stören sich natürlich alle gegenseitig aber die die idee die ist schon.
Das ist nicht von der hand zu weisen dass sie ein massives objekt haben stört natürlich seine unmittelbare umgebung frage ist jetzt,
wie stark und wie groß und schwer muss dieses objekt sein und da haben sie natürlich weitreichende spekulation.
Und muss sich wirklich solch ein objekt übersehen haben ich weiß nicht wie viel waren's da fünf ergebnissen oder,
größe und das ist ja schon objekt was sie eigentlich selbst in korbach nicht so einfach übersehen können außer es steckt tatsächlich vor dem hintergrund galaktisch zentrum,
und ich sage noch einmal ja für die bahn störungen von dadurch das klar wurde in den siebziger achtziger das blut und nicht verantwortlich ist für die beinstellung von uranus und tun,
dass man dann den planeten x gesucht hat und nicht gefunden hat weil er nicht existieren in diesem ausmaß,
sollte eigentlich das licht dann oft auf auf dieses mysteriöse objekt,
werfen da und die bahn störungen von orangenes neptun wurden erklärt,
nachdem an orangenes neptun vorbeigeflogen ist und das schwere feld exakt bestimmt hatte und so exakt bestimmt hatte das also,
die massen so genau stimmt wurden wenn sie die dann in die bahn berechnung rein getan haben dass die.
Veranstaltungen in anführungsstrichen verschwunden sind.
Das heißt es war einfach.
Es war einfach eine.
Kenntnis über die massen diese objekte.
Ja und da gibt's darüber gibt es ein paper stammt aus derselben zeit.
Und damit wurde das postauto lat von planet x über den haufen geworfen es war ein poster gewesen.
Und es muss jetzt einfach die zeit zeigen was das was das mit diesem mysteriösen objekt da da zeigt,
schon schwierig ich auch vorzustellen wenn sie so viele kleine objekte relativ klein und sind ja einige so groß wie pluto aber die ersten die entdeckt worden waren ja ein paar hundert kilometer groß,
was dich schon entdeckt wurden das muss man ja jetzt nach zwanzig dreißig jahren.
Vom großes objekt prostituierte großes objekt zu übersehen schwierig.
Schwierig ja man kann nur hoffen dass das james dieses korb nachfolger vom habel teleskop jetzt auch zügig am start kommt
ist ja mehrfach verschoben worden soll aber nun in den nächsten jahren im betrieb,
dann könnt ihr auch nochmal spannend werden für einen möglichen,
kandidaten für new visions weil das auge schärfer ist dann sieht man vielleicht mehr beziehungsweise auch wenn noch solche,
fabulösen mysteriösen planeten herum eiern vielleicht findet man die bis dahin denk ich mal bildet sich jetzt unser sonnensystem eigentlich in so einem ganz harmonischen system ab so mit den gestalt planeten dem,
asteroiden gürtel dann den weiteren gas planeten und an diesem körperbild des weiteren auswurf das ganze umringt von dieser ja diffusen orten wolke
von der man irgendwie noch weniger weiß sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so eine zelle gepflegtes organismus das universum.
Und vor dem hintergrund der exot planeten die wir entdeckt haben sind ja schon mehrere tausend stück ist das sonnensystem immernoch ein exot,
oder die entdeckten exot planeten sind die exoten also wir haben noch nicht ein ein,
planeten system in diesen dimensionen,
wie das sonnensystem entdeckt irgendwann hat er hat schon planeten systeme entdeckt mit sechs sieben planeten aber so kompakt,
dass sie innerhalb der der mal kurban passen also nicht in diese dimension das sonnensystem über viele zehner astronomische einheiten,
da wird's noch spannend.
Jetzt wird auch was ganz,
das lassen wir jetzt mal offen ich habe jetzt heute vielen vielen dank für die ausführung zu pluto und der new visions mission jetzt mal wirklich weit draußen da ist es kalt jetzt gehen wir wieder zurück.
Auf die erde ich bedanke mich fürs zuhören hier bei raum seid und diesen monat geht's wieder weiter bis dahin,
bis bald.